DO YOU WANT TO GET BACK IN TV?
>> ONLY IF THERE IS NUDITY.
>> Sean: [LAUGHING].
>> YEAH, SO FAR THEY REFUSE!
>> Sean: I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN
GET THAT ON A NETWORK SHOW
ANYWAY ON.
>> I LIKE TALKING TO PEOPLE AND
DISCUSSING, WHAT Y'ALL THINK OF
THIS?
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: OBVIOUSLY, YOU CARE A
>> Sean: WHAT CHANGED YOU?
WHAT BOOKS?
WHAT SHIFTED YOUR POLITICAL
VIEWS?
>> WELL, MY EXPERIENCE IN THE
GREEN PARTY AND SOCIALIST PARTY
I FELT VERY MARGINALIZED THERE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T LIKE ISRAEL.
WHAT THIS IS THE WORST PLACE ON
EARTH.
HAVE YOU BEEN THERE?
>> Sean: I AM THE BIGGEST
>> IT'S A WONDERFUL PLACE WITH
PROBLEMS LIKE EVERY PLACE ELSE.
I DO A LOT OF DRINKING -- MEAN
THINKING AND I HAVE THE SOLUTION
FOR IT.
I HAVE ALWAYS SAID THIS FOR LIKE
20 YEARS.
JEWISH GRANDMOTHERS AND EVERYONE
WHO LIVES OVER THERE, IF WE
COULD WRITE UP A GRANDMA'S
TREATY AND PRESENT IT TO THE
POWER THAT WOULD BE THE FIFTY
FASTEST WAY TO SOLVE PROBLEMS.
THERE IS NO CHILD ON THE EARTH
>> Sean: THERE IS A LOT OF EVIL
TOO.
>> PEOPLE SAY GET RID OF YOUR
HATE.
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO HATE EVIL.
>> Sean: I HAVE AN IDEA.
AS I LISTEN TO YOU, YOU ARE VERY
SINCERE IN SAYING I WANT TO HAVE
A CONVERSATION.
I THINK THE COUNTRY HAS NEVER
BEEN THIS DIVIDED.
>> IT'S STUPID!
WE HAVE TO GET OUR MONEY BACK
FROM BOTH SIDES.
WE HAVE TO TALK TO EACH OTHER.
STAND UP AND INVITE A GUEST AND
HAVE A REAL CONVERSATION.
THAT WOULD SELLOUT IN THEATERS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND INVITE
>> I WOULD DO.
THAT WE SHOULD TURN THIS INTO
A GREAT TEACHABLE MOMENT.
THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE
CONVERSATIONS SO YOU CAN
SYNTHESIZE YOUR IDEAS AND COME
UP WITH A SOLUTION.
BECAUSE HE IS A SOLUTION GUY.
>> Sean: THE COUNTRY HAS GOTTEN
GAVE EVERY AMERICAN $30 MILLION
THEY WOULD STILL HATE HIM.
>> I THINK THEY ARE COMING
AROUND.
HIS STUFF IS COMING UP.
HIS APPROVAL.
>> Sean: I HAVEN'T ASKED YOU
ABOUT TOM ARNOLD.
DO YOU STILL LOVE HIM?
>> DO I STILL LOVE HIM?
>> Sean: APPARENTLY NOT.
DID HE CALL YOU?
>> HELL NO.
THAT WAS 25 YEARS AGO!
THAT WAS TWO HUSBANDS AGO.
>> Sean: HOW MANY TOTAL?
I AM NOT KEEPING UP.
16 YEARS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY HE STILL LIKES
ME BUT HE DOES.
>> Sean: HE CALLS YOU SMOKING.
>> BECAUSE I WEAR A RUBBER GLOVE
AND HAT IN THE ALLEY.
HE DIDN'T KNOW AND I LIED.
ON TOP OF ALL OF THIS OTHER
STUFF, HE OPENS UP YAHOO AND
HE SAID -- BECAUSE HE KNEW I
WOULD KILL HIM IN ME MADE ME
MAD.
SWEETHEART, YOU LIED TO ME ABOUT
SMOKING, DIDN'T YOU?
>> Sean: WHAT DID YOU SAY?
>> GET OUT.
>> Sean: IN MY ALL MY CAREERS ON
TELEVISION, THERE HAVE BEEN
CONTROVERSIES AND SAMANTHA STILL
HAS HER SHOW.
BILL MAR GOT FIRED AT ABC.
I SAID I AM NOT IN FAVOR OF
BOYCOTTS.
I THINK PEOPLE WHEN THEY MAKE
MISTAKES -- I THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE FAIR.
GOOD.
FORGET THE MEDIA.
>> 28 MILLION TUNED INTO MY SHOW
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO SEE
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HELP
NOTHING.
PEOPLE WANT TO HEAR THE BALANCE
AND THE TRUTH.
ANYTHING NOT BASED ON FACTS AND
DATA AND PURE EMOTIONS, THAT
AIN'T RIGHT.
>> Sean: MAYBE YOU COULD DO
STAND UP WITH THIS A PART OF IT.
YOU STAND UP AND THEN SIT DOWN
AND HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH
SOMEONE YOU DISAGREE WITH.
>> Sean: I WON'T KICK YOU OUT.
WHEN I WAS 13 AND THEY WERE
GOOD.
>> Sean: YOU SMOKED THEM AFTER
ALL OF THESE YEARS LATER?
>> YES, AND I THANK YOU FOR THE
FRIENDSHIP.
YOU HELPED ME A LOT AND SO DID A